l'autre blanchemaison bonjour merci
d'être avec nous ce matin dans la
matinale de rtl france alors une
transition périlleuse a dénoncé par john
hayden quel intérêt pour donald trump
alors je crois qu'elle de sujets et là
dans le sujet médiatique donald trump a
décidé d'occuper tout le terrain
médiatique en tout cas le au maximum
jusqu'au 1 janvier et c'est ce qu'il
arrive puisque tous les jours il prend
des décisions qui paraît choquant
d'ailleurs pour dédé d'acteurs attaché
au fonctionnement démocratique des
institutions et les ce que thomas hayden
a fait hier c'est qu'il ait fait de
reprendre la main en réalité en se
plaçant sur un terrain qui est un très
bon terrain qui est le terrain de la
sécurité nationale en disant l'attitude
de trump est totalement irresponsable
d'autre part les agences quand quelque
chose avec la sécurité sont dans un état
désastreux scène politique de la terre
brûlée systématiquement menés par trump
fait peser un risque sur la sécurité
nationale américaine
ac deuxième sujet c'est le risque que
cela fait peser sur la sécurité
nationale américaine d'air en effet s'il
y avait un vide entre la présidence
trempé et la présidence by dell cela
serait très risqué la plus grande
puissance du monde ne peut pas être aux
abonnés absents pendant quelques jours
et en ses impressions que joe biden a
cherché à créer en disant que au
ministère de la défense que au bureau du
budget ont refusé à son équipe un
certain nombre d'informations
est-ce qu'il a exagéré c'est possible
parce que via le congrès il va
bénéficier
cependant l'incident de l'information
notamment en matière budgétaire mais
c'est vrai que c'est le bureau du budget
du président qui décide de l'exécution
du budget et que le président élu le
président entrant a besoin de savoir
quelques temps auparavant exactement
quelle est la situation qu'elle était
alors évidemment matière de sécurité il
a besoin lui et son équipe d'avoir des
briefings tout à fait exhaustif de la
part des différentes agences qui
s'occupe de questions de sécurité ce qui
manifestement départ car sur le but
de la défense donald trump avait imposé
un veto à la nuit dernière la chambre
des représentants il passer outre et
passer outre les documents réunis
d'ailleurs qu'est-ce que ça signifie
claude a goûté ça signifie en effet que
le torchon brûle avec le congrès et qu'
un certain nombre de membres de la
chambre des représentants qui
appartiennent au parti républicain ont
voté contre contre trappe
bien sûr on sait qu'à la chambre des
représentants ce sont les démocrates
pour la majorité
mais le vote d'hier soir a été acquis
bien au delà d'une simple majorité est
en effet la chambre des représentants
estiment qu' il est essentiel pour la
continuité des pouvoirs que le budget de
la défense soit votée si ensuite il doit
être amendé c'est une autre question qui
pourrait être examinée plus tard il peut
pas y avoir d'interruption dans la
définition des fonds dont disposera
l'administration américaine après le 20
janvier
et c'est tout à fait important pour la
sécurité des états unis
donc en effet joe biden a gagné à un
autre point hier et en matière plus de
manches maison de défense de sécurité
nationale un sujet sur la table
aujourd'hui aux états unis
est-ce que zhu bayonne va avoir une
politique différente de celle de son
prédécesseur
ben elle sera différente au moins dans
dans leurs dents dans l'esprit et dans
la forme puisque tout le monde pense et
joe biden l'a dit il l'a dit dans les
interviews à l'internât la revue soit
rien faire il a dit dans des dents des
contacts divers souhaite mettre la
diplomatie au centre des relations
extérieures la guerre c'est l'échec de
la diplomatie et par conséquent faire
avoir redéployé la diplomatie américaine
avec le personnel le plus compétent
possible donner plus de prévisibilité à
la diplomatie américaine
et d'ailleurs il va avoir à le démontrer
en prenant tout de suite très rapidement
dans les premiers
jour quelques décisions la première
décision qu'il a à prendre
'cela dit qu'il le ferait c'est la
prolongation du traité new start c'est
une demande russe parce que le traité
new start vient à échéance le 5 février
prochain
et si le dernier traité de ce qu'on
appelle la ham ce contrôle c'est à dire
le contrôle des armements
joe biden et les démocrates sont décidés
à prolonger ce traité de quelques mois
d'un an
il ne l'a pas dit de façon à réamorcer
discussions sur ces sujets avec la
russie que c'est un prêté entre les
états unis et la russie
cela permettra d'amorcer d'ailleurs
probablement d'autres discussions et
notre négociation sur le sujet du
contrôle des armements qui a été tout à
fait maltraiter par l'administration de
trump puisque les principaux traités ont
été dénoncés donc ça c'est un premier
point sur lequel il y aura une
différence
le second point c'est la réintégration
dans l'accord de la coop 21 de paris sur
le réchauffement climatique
et cela va changer complètement en effet
l'impression que crée la diplomatie
américaine dans le monde
le troisième sujet sera très
probablement là le retour en grâce de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé et
le fait que
joe biden souhaite que les travaux sur
les pandémies actuelles et futures
puissent être menées avec l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
donc un retour au multilatéralisme qui
avait été dénoncée maltraité par trump
qui comptait plus sur les rapports de
force et les négociations bilatérales
comme il le disait je suis un homme qui
sait faire les deals comme dans le
business
ça n'a pas marché à tous les coups en
tout cas sur un sujet aussi important
que la corée du nord
eh bien ça a échoué puisque finalement
kim jong-un a continué tranquillement à
préparer ses armes nucléaires alors en
revanche votre sujet joe biden a indiqué
que les états unis reviendraient à
l'intérieur du traité sur la limitation
de la nucléaire en iran le fameux traité
jiechi bio et ceci est important parce
que ça permettra de réamorcer aussi une
négociation avec l'iran sur les
conditions du retour des etats unis et
sur l'application par l'iran de toutes
les obligations auxquelles ce traité
l'obligent à savoir d'arrêter un certain
nombre de travaux d'enrichissement
d'uranium et d'arrêter la poursuite de
la tra vocation d'une arme nucléaire
donc tout ça ce sont des changements
très importants il y en aura sans doute
d'autres mais ce sont les plus urgents
ce sont ceux du premier mois merci
beaucoup claude blanche maison pour
votre analyse ce matin dans la matinale